Black Rifle coffee is going to be really
positive for people who are probably
right leaning in terms of their
associations with that brand it'll
probably be kind of negative for the the
people who are more left landing and
that's okay because they're like we can
sell to half the population for most of
these things I'm just looking at what is
the percentage likelihood that people
will adhere or comply with the requests
that the brand makes of them buy my
thing go to this thing whatever that's
why you can have somebody who has a huge
brand in terms of uh the amount of
people who are aware of it but have very
low ability to direct or change Behavior